Hey guys!
I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop.
You may notice that I'm sitting around in the dark today, and that's because today
We're gonna be doing some experiments with glow sticks.
We've got a huge selection of different glow sticks right here,
And we're gonna see what we can learn about them just by playing around.
we'll see what happens if we open some up and
Really get a feel for what these things are like. What's the texture of the fluid like? Does it have a smell does it have?
A taste? What happens if we combine lots of glow sticks together?
Can we pull out the
Separate fluid chemicals inside the glow sticks? And then combine them when we're ready to have a large amount of glow
Today is the day to learn all of these things
The first step will be cracking open one of these plastic tubes and seeing what's going on inside
when I look at one of these tubes up close I can see that there's liquid coming up to about here and
Just below that is what appears to be a glass vial
I'm gonna try and cut the plastic off above the level of the liquid so that when it cuts. It doesn't just leak out everywhere
All right the top of that kind of came off pretty easily
There's definitely some liquid running out
So may be kind of hard to see
But there's now what looks like maybe a teaspoon of clear liquid down inside this bowl
And I have a vial which sounds like it's made of glass
And I think it is because I'm pretty sure these are activated by cracking the glass vial
inside the plastic tube
Has a slightly sweet smell not like sugary sweet, but some sort of chemical sweet
Interesting now we've got our vial which I think is glass and i'm gonna see if I can crack this the same way
I'm just gonna see if our pliers and take the top off of this
Hopefully not
Shoot glass bits everywhere. I'm gonna cover with my hand a little bit. Just so it doesn't shoot shards of glass throughout the kitchen..
It sounded kind of like when you pop a Christmas light bulb and this is also full liquid
So let's see what happens if we pour this liquid into that liquid I bet it starts glowing
Fun kind of swirl patterns in there when it's not mixed all the way yeah that
Bowl is looking pretty good
It's almost acting as a little bit of a fiberoptic Bowl the edges of it look like they're glowing quite a bit
So there is the contents of a single glow stick it's not much like I said that looks like it's about one
Teaspoon of liquid maybe a little bit more, but not a lot all right now
I don't know. What kind of liquid says is so I'm just gonna dip my gloved hand into it
It does feel pretty oily. This doesn't feel like a water substance on the hands. It just feels like oil
It's very slippery
That was the result of getting one glow sticks worth of fluid. I kind of wonder. What would happen if we got like
20 glow sticks worth of fluid together
We've got eight cups here, and I'm gonna divide it out into the four different colors and the two different liquids for each color
There's no visible blue dye in this it looks clear
I only know that it's going to be blue because the package says there is one and I already cracked some other ones open so
It looks clear at this point, but when I hit it with a black light
It glows blue the yellow. Glows yellow the green glows green
Also, interesting is the activating fluid down at the bottom doesn't seem to glow at all it looks purple on video
But that's just because the blacklight looks purple. It's not fluorescing the way that the vials are a
Pink fluorescing in the blacklight as well so all of the dyes, and whatever else is in that vial lights up under a blacklight
That's pretty neat all of our activator fluid is now harvested
So we need to crack open the glass vials and pour that into some separate cups
I'm also going to clean off each glass vial with a paper towel to get rid of the excess oil on the outside
Because I don't want it to start glowing before I start combining oh
And
Something's already activating. We're getting some blue showing up
Maybe I need to make sure to clean off my pliers better, so this is the empty cup or all of my blue. Dye
glass vial fluid into here
Looks like a pretty similar consistency
This also feels oily
Maybe even more oily than the other fluid we now have our for fluids drained into four cups with the four cups of their respective
Activators, let's hit this with a blacklight again, and see how it's looking look pretty good. Well. It was in the sticks
Whoo look at that. I love that blue like there's no color
Until you hit it with the blacklight, and then it is vibrantly
Brilliantly blue pink magenta red whatever color you want to call that it's it's bright
We now have glow stick fluid out of 20 glow sticks divided up into its four different colors
And I think it's time we start combining
I want to see what happens if we have five glow sticks worth of fluid at once in a cup and then once we've got
All four I think we're gonna see what happens if we have 20 glow sticks worth of fluid in a cup
It looks like there's a little bit more of the activator fluid than the glow fluid just eyeballing it. I would say it's 60% activator
40% die here go pouring the activator into the dye
Yeah
It's a nice bright glow, let's do the other colors
That's a pretty great glow I would say that the green one is definitely brighter than the other three
But all three of them are putting off some pretty good light. Let's put this in rainbow order for you
slightly
Obsessive people out there now. I want to see what happens if we mix them
Let's see what happens if we mix the magenta and the yellow
I wonder if we can get orange by doing that there are orange glow sticks, and I have some of those
But I want to see if we can get orange just by mixing the magenta and yellow. All right. Let's try some pink
magenta color
and
some yellow
Hmm that is a really cool. Swirl look right there. They haven't mixed together on their own
There's little bits of orange in there, but right there. It just looks like swirls of glowing fire or something, ooh
That is mixing and now we have orange glow fluid
That's actually interesting though like it doesn't look pure orange somehow it has like a slight green tint to it
It's thicker in some spots. Where looks really orange, but kind of right behind the thick spot
There's a thin spot, and they have almost looks and green. Oh, man. We've almost got the whole rainbow here
I think we have to see if we can push that just a little farther
And get purple. I'll pour off a little bit of blue add a little bit of magenta see if we can get a violet oh
Yeah a glow rainbow
Well that looks pretty great, and now I think we need to combine them all together and see how they look
I don't know what color that's gonna be normal if you mix all these colors together
You're gonna get a murky brown, but I'm having a hard time imagining. What does glowing Brown look like?
Let's find out
So apart just looks like fire and a cup
Curiously all of the colors combined gave us just orange. I really thought we would lose more of that orange color
I don't know what I thought it would turn into
The blue seemed like it was so vibrant compared to the red and the yellow that I thought it would overpower it
But it hasn't I tilt it like this you can see where it's thin at the back
That's what I'm talking about that looks green in real life. It's not just a trick of a camera
Looking at this I would say we probably have I don't know about half a cup
Maybe a little less than half a cup of fluid. It's glowing quite nicely very orange, which is
Interesting since we didn't start with any orange fluid this is
yellow or magenta or blue and our green and those combined to make bright orange wouldn't have guessed that I
Think I know where that smell
What that smell reminds me of if you've ever used a wasp trap that has a liquid bait in it?
It smells a lot like that liquid bait
pod
Still pretty oily think that's interesting on my black. Glove that just looks green
That's the same stuff that looks orange in the container, but smeared onto my fingers it looks green
Well I have to try this it says non-toxic on the packaging I'm not gonna swallow it
Is it working ah I can feel it tingling on like gum
I've heard the glowsticks will glow a much brighter when they're warm and much less when they're cold
So I've got a set of glow sticks
and I'm gonna set them in this cup of hot water and
We'll let them heat up for a bit after that will activate them and compare that to a set of glow sticks that have been
cooling down in the freezer for several minutes on this side
We have our glow sticks, which have been sitting in the freezer for about 45 minutes and this side
We've got glow sticks that have been sitting in hot water for I don't know 20 minutes
So let's try cracking all eight and see which glow the best
first the cold ones
Oh boy
Really not a very intense glow yet
Pink ones barely going at all all right now for the warm ones
Wow
Well, I'm gonna say that is confirmed
Heating it up. Definitely makes it put off more light
Here's our cold ones
Which barely seem like they're glowing at all in every case the warm one is glowing way more than the cold one
Warmth definitely makes a difference cold ones not as bright
Although it's also interesting that I believe if it's colder it will last longer
So it won't put out as much light all at once but over time it might put out the same amount of light
There's something floating on the top of this water
And I got this cup it was just one of the cups that had some activator in it
Which makes me think that maybe the oily?
Feel of the glowsticks isn't just in my head, maybe it's actually an oil of some sort
So let's see what happens if we try and mix a little bit of our glow stick fluid with some water
There's a little bit of water at the bottom of that cup. Let's pour in some glow stick fluid and see what happens
Yeah, they don't mix
You can see that our glow fluid is underneath our layer of water, and interestingly once again. It looks green
We go we can see the glow fluid comes up to about here, and then the water is just sitting on top of it
So the two do not mix together
Soap is an emulsifier that can often let polar and nonpolar fluids bond
So let's add some of that and see if we can get them to mix
Mmm. The soap is activating with the Glo fluid itself
Wow that's getting a lot brighter
Which I think is probably a result of the very warm water that I was using which lends some support to the idea that heat
Will make these glow more intensely compare that to our other fluid. Here's the the difference between the two at the moment
This is putting off a lot more light after being mixed with warm water and even with the soap
It's still separating back out mostly now. That's so point in and it immediately started doing something really cool
I don't what it was but I have to try it again
So I'm gonna pour off a little bit more of our glow fluid here
I'm just gonna drip some soap in without any of a warm water this time
Elgar's really cool kind of reminds me of when we made patterns in milk with food coloring by dripping in some liquid soap
Okay, so
Now it's getting even brighter
But there's no hot water in this one
So I think soap might chemically activate this stuff either that or it's just the stirring motion
But I think it's the soap now
I want to see just how bright we can get some of this to go
We know that heat makes them brighter, and it seems that adding soap makes them brighter as well
So let's take both of these fluids let them sit in a bath of warm water for a few minutes
then combine them with a little bit of soap and see if we can just get like an ultra bright glowing lantern look I
Think our two different fluid. Halves are ready and probably fairly warm after sitting in that so let's take those out
Let's combine them together and then add soap and see how bright this thing gets this is five green glow sticks worth of fluid oh
That's just the warm fluids mixed together that is already
You know affects us the colour that'll kill Superman right there alright. Let's try adding a drop of soap
Yep that gets a lot right oh my gosh that is insanely bright
I don't think it's gonna last very long, but something about the soap pulls all the chemical reaction into one spot
And it just boy that is a lantern check this out scary stories tonight
gosh that is
Nuts and it doesn't last for like it's already getting dimmer for sure, but for just a couple of seconds that is just
Exploding with brightness we've got a ton more glow sticks
So if you've got some cool ideas what you want to see us do with them let us know down in the comments
Hey guys. Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber yet
Just hit the bottom to get in the club if you haven't seen our last video
Or you want to watch it again click up here at the top
Check it out down there
If you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch next that's it for now have fun
Be safe, and see you tomorrow